- Hypothèque, épicerie, essence;
la vie a coûté cher en 2022.
- Je peux dire que oui,
je m'inquiète.
- On vient d'avoir un petit bébt
vrai qu'en ce moment on est
obligés de se fixer un budget
un petit peu pour les dépenses
qui sont un petit peu
moins utiles.
- Les indicateurs sont au rouge.
Nombreux sont ceux qui, faute
d'arriver à joindre les deux
bouts, se tournent vers
des syndic de faillite.
SOPHIE DÉSAUTELS, syndic autori.
redressement financer, Raymond C
- Depuis avril on voit vraiment
une hausse d d dossiers
d'insolvabilité et on voit que
les gens commencent à avoir
de plus en plus de difficulté
à respecter leurs engenenents
financiers.
- Entre les mois de novembre
2021 et 2022, le nombre
de dossiers d'insolvabilité
a augmenté de 9,papapar rapport
à la même période l'année
précédente. C'est ce que
rapporte le Bureau duriririrints
et c'est aussi ce que constate
Sophie Désautels sur le terraint
ralentir dans les prochains
mois, les prix des biens
et services essentiels auxquels
on a besoin vont rester élevés.
- De là l'importance, rappelle-
t-elle, d'établir un budget
annuel.
- En fait, l'importance du
budget c'est d'avoir un budget
réaliste, un vrai budget, et
selon notre réalité financière
à nous.
- On a toujours fait un budget.
C'est bien important, puis là,
bien, il va y avoir de grosses
modifications.
- Çeseseseses années
qu'on fait ça, fait que...
- Le mois de janvier est
toujours occupé chez Option
Consommateurs qui offre
le service de consultation
budgétaire gratuitement.Mais Joe
que la clientèle change.
JOHANNE LEBLANC, conseillère
budgétaire, Option consommateurs
- Il y a de plus en plus de gens
qui ne sont pas dans des classes
défavorisées qui font appel
à notre service.
- Et quelle que soit sa
situation financière, le pire
ennemi du budget est le déni.
- C'est facile de se tourner
vers le crédit. Là, si on
utilise le crédit, on utilise
le crédit, nécessairement,
à moment donné, la réalité
va nous rattraper.
- D'ailleurs, les Canadiens
comptent de plus en plus
sur leur carte de crédit.
C'est ce que révélait Equifax
Canada en décembre dernier.
La dette à la consommation
continue d'augmenter.
L'endettement moyen des
consommateurs est de plus
de 21 000 $.
Ici Kim Vermette,
Radio-Canada, Montréa